Amen. So Dr. Zaky, Ramadan is a month of
opportunities. It's a month of blessed
opportunities.
What are the conditions that a person
needs to have these deeds accepted by
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala?
>> The basic two conditions are number one
is the intention.
It should only be for Allah subhanana wa
tala and no one else. Whatever deed you
do, it should only be for Allah
subhanana wa tala and no one else. This
is very important. If this condition is
not met, then all your deeds are wasted.
And Allah subhanaa tala says in the
Quran in surah chapter number 98 verse
number five, it says that
you worship none but Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala
and you do it only for him and for no
one else.
It is further mentioned
in surah insan chapter number 76 verse
number 9. It says that we have fed you
for the sake of Allah subhanaa tala for
the pleasure of Allah subhanaa tala. We
do not require any reward from you nor
do you require any returns. That means
if you feed someone it is for the sake
of Allah subhananaa tala. Not seeking a
reward or not seeking anything in
return. This is a very important factor
that we should note. All your actions
should be for the sake of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala. That's a very important
factor. And further it's mentioned in
the Quran in surah surah chapter number
42 verse number 20 that if you do a deed
for the tilt for the reward in the
hereafter Allah subhanana wa ta'ala will
multiply your reward your tilt in the
hereafter. And if you do a deed or any
action for a reward in this world, Allah
will give you the reward in this world,
but you'll have no share in the
hereafter.
Allah repeated that message in surah hud
chapter number 11 verse number 15 and 16
that anyone who seeks the reward in this
world or does any deed for this world
and for the glitter of this world Allah
subhananau wa ta'ala will surely give
him in this world but he will have no
share in the hereafter except fire
except hell
and all his deeds
will not be useful in the hereafter. So
therefore, whatever we do should be for
Allah subhana wa t'ala. And the second
califf of Islamat
Omar, may Allah be pleased with him,
it's mentioned in say Bkari volume
number one had number one, may Allah be
pleased with him. He said that the
beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said
which means your deeds are judged on
your intention.
And the prophet further said that
all your actions are based on your
intention. And anyone who has migrated
for Allah and his rasool, he has
migrated for Allah and his. If anyone
has in hijra migrated for the worldly
benefits or for marriage, he has
migrated for the worldly benefits and
marriage. So nia is very important and
this is further repeated
in another hadith in Sai Muslim volume
number four had number 7114.
It says that our beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said that
Allah subhanaa tala says that I am alone
sufficient. I do not require any
associate and if anyone does any deed
for anyone else as well as for me I
renounce that for the person who he has
associated to. That means you can't do
part of the deed for Allah and part for
someone else. You have to do completely
for the sake of Allah subhana wa tala
only for him and no one else. Allah does
not like anyone associating anything
with him. That's very important. So this
is a basic point that is the nia. The
second point to be noted for our deed to
be acceptable is that our deed should be
based on the sharia. It should be in
accordance to Allah and his accordance
to the teachings of the Quran and
teachings of our beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
It's mentioned in say Muslim volume
number three
had number 4267
where beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said that if your deeds and
actions are not according to our way
according to religion of Islam according
to Quran and say hadith then that is
rejected that means for a deed to be
accepted it should be according to Quran
and say hadith
and it's also mentioned in another Say
Hadith of Abu Daud
number three had number 4950
our beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said
that he told the people that follow my
example and the example of
that's the rightly guided callus.
So if you follow them and cling to it
with I that means strongly follow it the
sunnah of the prophet and my sunnah the
prophet said that his sunnah his way and
the way of the far that is rightly
cared. So for a deed to be accepted a
should be only for Allah subhana wa tala
and it should be according to the sharia
Quran and say hadith.